going back to the generational thing all
right I had a thought do you think every
generation is destined to get more horny
than the previous
generation do you know what made me
think this so I was like the interet not
just not just the internet but uh so I
had had I was uh I was like on a trip
and we had like a night where we were
watching like the biggest hits of the
2000s whatever and a video of tattoo
came on do you remember tattoo yeah [__]
yeah all the things she said yeah
[__] love that song do you remember
how much of a [__] storm it caused
because it just had two like girls in
Rain like making out and everyone's like
oh this is the [__] holy [__] and
parents were like no this we can't show
this to the children it's too sexualized
it's too edgy I don't remember this at
all they were huge in Japan yeah it
might have been just before like just
before Russian girls right yeah yeah two
Russian girls like it it was it was
massive for me when uh when when it came
out um and I it came on and then I
remember looking at it I'm like [__]
this is tame as [__] man this is well
even even like a little bit after that
right like when we were growing up like
I remember being you know [__] I
don't remember remember how old I was it
was definitely before I hit puberty and
you watch [__] Christina agulara
music videos and you're just like God
damn like I don't want my parents
walking in on me on this like all right
then I think there's a there's a very
important question to ask to to help
answer your question which is do you
think people are born with weird Kinks
or is it something that you're
introduced to and you're like oh I think
I think it's all about introduction
right you think so do you think that
like if you were a feet person yeah
right oh I guess feet that doesn't count
because you'd always see feet but if you
in a s weird like um I know what's a
weird fetish armpits no you'd see that a
lot you see armpits like you wouldn't
see natur like uh you know who's into
arm
no but like I like you see yeah on oh
yeah I was going to do this you could
easily if you were like a medieval
peasant right you were in like you in
800 in you could easily see a woman open
up a thing go actually hold on a second
I [__] [__] with the armpits but like
you would never be introduced to like
cucking right unless maybe happened to
you and you were like hold on but like
the normal person I don't know man
you're in Japan the normal person not be
introduced to like NTR right sure sure
most most people okay so I'm sure
there's some situation okay yeah most
people wouldn't be introduced to NTR
right yeah so the theory is like would
would you have been born being like I am
going to like NTR at some point or is it
like I have to then show you and then
you're like huh I don't even think it's
about showing I think it's just about
like the the number of stimuli that you
are subject to Growing Up all just kind
of combin together into like clicking to
be like I like so then so then so okay
cuz hypothetically think about it if
there was a person who was born right
and they spent their entire like first
18 he comes out he comes out with the
mother's vagina he's like Mama I am a
[__] do you know what your first words
were
[__] say say say say m
co no okay like let's think about this
hypothetically right if there was a
child who was born right and for the
first in Japan impossible yeah not in
Japan let's say Europe uh you know they
were born and for the first let's say 20
years they were born in a room and they
spent their entire lifetime in a room
which has like little to no stimuli
right like nothing in their room like
you know bare minimum human interaction
that is deemed as normal like no access
to the internet anything that kind of
stuff do you think they'll be able to
develop finishes from
that I don't think they would have
mental capacity to
function so we answer question I think I
think there is you might be born with
like maybe some brain chemicals like
leaning towards maybe taking in certain
stimuli that so then we answer G's
question then cuz Gant saying is the
next Generation no I think I just think
the current generation is exposed to a
lot more Concepts yeah and espe with the
internet porn is very easily accessible
now and you know back in the day even
like 20 years ago you had to go to a
[__] store and buy it um and even if
you opened up like Playboy magazines
like 10 20 years ago you would you
wouldn't see like the weird [__] that
you see now so I feel like it was more
of a joined like it was more of a
communal thing where you're like did you
see the Playboy you know did you see the
X model who is the hottest right whereas
now it's like what are you into and
someone's like oh I like getting shat on
you're like
okay okay that's uh and to you cuz
you've had no exposure King Shame you
had no exposure to that you're like
that's [__] disgusting why would you
do that for him it's like he's exposed
and then I think I think that's also as
a result of the fact that now like the
internet is we are not ready for the
internet well that's the thing we been
[__] because people go on the internet
and now we're so over stimulated that
the stuff that we deemed is like [__]
up 10 20 years ago is just like
normalized now so people are just
looking for the next thing do you think
by the time we die there'll be studies
like showing that the internet was just
like we just [__] weren't ready for
the internet like it like I think I
think there are probably studies that
are have already it's probably already
done I think it would be more helpful
when it's like we're all dead said and
done you know what I mean when it's you
know when they can really sit back and
look ah the whole life okay let's have a
look see here what happened when the
internet happened so how did it come to
him liking NTR let's find out let's
dissect this brain I'm curious I mean I
don't even think NTR like I I saw like I
saw another tweet where it was just this
fetish of this person I don't I can't I
don't know if it was a guy or a girl
just in like full latex just getting
vacuumed to uh have you seen
that and I see that and I'm just like
like euphoric how do you even like where
does this even come from like bro that
has to start with a porn addiction right
because here see like outfits and
they're like oh that's [__] hot yeah
here's here's the thing like some things
I can like I have a theory that you know
most fetches come from maybe how we were
raised something to do with like what we
experienced time I have I have a theory
that we were probably like forbidden to
like this kind of stuff or we were told
this thing is bad so like mentally we we
know this thing is bad and that's why it
kind P so well yeah that's true it's a
it's a the ultimate taboo yeah yeah
right I think for some people breaking
taboos is inherently attractive yeah
yeah exactly exactly so I I think that's
where a lot of fetishes starts you know
um being vacuumed in a latex suit I'm
like how many you're missing the steps
how how many later I I can connect the
taboo dots I can't connect the vacuum
sucked up right also I imagine I don't
even know if that's Tabo I imagine like
back in the day the only people who
could afford to indulge in [__] up
Kinks were like ultra wealthy like
landlords they were like well my thing
is that I love people being maimed or
something while you know or I love
people being branded that's my king
right you know and so back then it was
you know it's probably unlimited to like
people who had money yeah I think I
think like peasants were like well [__]
I'm just trying to get by I'm just
trying to get some food are you saying
fetishes are privileges I think it
issh just okay just just think about the
latex latex suit how much is a latex
suit yeah think about that for a second
able to hook that up get get get to a
get you need to like probably 3D print
you need you need to either learn to
learn like to fre 3D print a device to
be able to vacuum yourself or someone
has gone out and designed that for you
which you must have paid a premium
[__] price buy buying a [__] doll
buying a doll that you can [__] is
expensive that a privilege and God
forbid we already know how much furries
like spend on furry suit they're [__]
funding the economy by themselves I hate
how much this makes
sense you know I can see why this
generation feels like they're doomed
when we hear about this kind of [__]
it's just like wine you know wine is a
is a very expensive hobby as is jacking
off sometimes when when Society has gone
down and everyone is homeless it'll be
the furries having the last laugh
because they'll be the last group of
people with money I swear to God they
have all the money
they we can make it through the harsh
winter in our
suits you know fur fur for the most part
yeah sleeping they're sleeping good when
we have the Great Depression part two
all we're going to see on the streets
are people in fursuits man cuz that's
that's the only people with money left
in the world that's all I'm saying man
every furry I met they've been pretty
chill as well yeah they've
Met has been like the chillest dudes
they've been very chill and uh they have
also uh normally been uh very
financially well off as well to afford
the hobby that they do they are they
prop up the artist sphere online it's a
Well documented fil on Jesus Christ
maybe maybe like fet I feel like with
the overexposure of the internet and
with the overexposure of new things I
feel like this [__] latex suit there
must be why are you so obsessed with
this latex Su got I just because it
sounds absurd do you want a latex suit
for your birthday no I'm just I just
want to know you say yes we're ending
the podcast really I'm I'll help him I
want to see where it goes I'm just
genuinely curious what the steps are you
know like like genuinely well it's like
that it's like that famous video of the
guy like who bought like the full latex
like dog suit right and like and like
and like acts like a dog he like sleeps
in a
giant he's like a BRI guy I think okay
first of all I take offense to that
probably English first of all okay okay
my bad my bad uh what about wasn't that
guy in Japan that wanted to be a dog so
he spent I mean that's the that's the
least weird thing in Japan when it comes
to fetishes bro there was a dude who
married H Miku [__] body pillar he
married the DS as well like man like
it's cool that we're like open to cool
things like that but also at the same
time you shouldn't you shouldn't do that
straight up should not marry a DS yeah
um I I just think that that's a bad idea
we shouldn't be congratulating at all
yeah we shouldn't be rewarding Behavior
like that ultimately like I think it's
funny and like it's it makes a very good
BuzzFeed article but that's about it I
mean I would prefer that you just be
asexual at that point you know cuz I can
I can kind of vibe with that I can I can
understand that um if you know you know
some people are just why that way uh if
you are falling in love with a DS I see
that as something that you're replacing
a animate object asexuality is not
doesn't mean the lack of romance there
so they still you know you still be in a
relationship uh you just might not be
physical it so you know whereas a DS you
can't have either so you just well I I
see the DS as you replacing something
that you couldn't get you know because
it's tough right because I guess how do
you how do you like if if if Joey comes
to us tomorrow and he's like guys I fall
in love with my PSP V first of all great
choice to console to fall in love with
second of all also it's called a PS uh
yeah it is it's great yeah they amazing
games on it what are youing like what
what all those amazing exclusives that
were only on the PS well 90% of them
never came out of Japan so outside of
Japan yeah outside it was a great
console uh and Japan [__] used it
until like five years ago yeah uh anyway
it was the only country pspv to sorry
PSV to sorry to insult you and your wife
um I think I'd be like hey Joy what's
going on like like I wouldn't be like
dude that's cool I'm Progressive I'm
like no Joey what's wrong like there's
something's gone wrong here yeah and I
and you know I think that's fair we
shouldn't be like yeah yes to everything
I think sometimes we should be like wait
hold on a second no yeah don't this is a
terrible what has happened can you
please think about this can you talk to
us tell me what happened um and if you
don't have that in your life then
there's another there's even bigger
problem going on where were that dude's
friends when he married the DS genuine
question what
yeah exactly who stopped him who was
like hey man I really think this might
not be a good idea do you think his
friends would have stopped him when his
parents were like he loves him this is
presuming that this was a legit thing
and not like some kind of publicity St
if publicity St whatever but if it is a
real apparently it was legit okay well
that's like he went to the W office and
signed papers and [__] oh my God and
they they did it yeah that's crazy they
would let a man marry a DI but not let
two gays marry that's that I mean that's
all I'm going to say that's crazy you
can marry DS that's why society's doomed
brother yeah um
I don't have anything to add on to that
man that's just a [__] bombshell and
I'm just like wait really get no there's
no way he legally got married there must
been a ceremony there's no way he
legally I don't believe guy get on it
guy
guy guy behind computer look it
up Japanese man has married a character
in a popular video game taking her and
his handheld game console on an overseas
honeymoon there's no way it's a real
marriage I I think it must just be
publish your son okay four picture why
does it look like young PRD in that one
picture oh my
God the on the one on the fourth one you
know what I mean like a PRD fake
character in one of his
[Laughter]
skits uh yeah where is the news on that
but at which point are you just like you
know the guy married the body pillar at
which point are you just like you know
what I'm happy that you're happy you
know like where did you draw the line of
that I guess I draw the line when it's a
Nintendo console you know I think that's
where I draw the line honestly did uh
whoever owns Hudson and Miku have to
sign off on the marriage well I think in
the case of the DS one it wasn't Hudson
and Miku it was a oh yeah it was it was
a character from a dating simulator
Called Love plus yeah because it was one
of the first dating Sims that was kind
of AR technology cuz with the DS I think
he had like a GPS or something and you
could you could literally take this
camera on it right yeah yeah you could
literally take this virtual girl on
Virtual dates and it was one of the very
first of its kind maybe I don't know why
I'm so adverse to the idea I'm honestly
like I reckon if I was the developer of
that like visual novel I would have
absolutely been on border with it
because that is amazing promotion for
the game I'm so torned because at the
same time what if the guy's happy like
if he's genuinely happy what can I like
is there a reason why he shouldn't do it
I'm so torn cuz I'm like you shouldn't
be allowed to do this no so if he's
really happy and that made him happy who
am I to rob that man of his happiness
yeah but there's other ways to be happy
you know yeah that are not like
impossible to obtain but then I think
about like some friends I have where
they where I think they're happy and
they drink but I'm like I think they
could be happy other ways it happens to
be that drinking is what makes them
happy right now you know what I mean so
I'm really T I'm like you are entitled
to your happiness yeah sure yeah of
course but is that happiness like to a
self- detriment like is that you know I
don't know I don't know yeah I mean he
looks [__] happy in that picture he
looks very happy that's not that was
2020 as well that's years lat remember I
remember this advert he must be just
going along with it no no shot bro I
don't believe it I I don't believe it's
real I don't I don't no way did you see
that Tinder added a Pay to Win function
now $500 a month $500 yeah if you are
paying $500 for Tinder you all have
actually I think I'd rather get you like
marry to this is like the different DS
now
if I if I knew if I knew my friend was
paying for that Tinder premium I'm
buying him a DS I'll be like yo bro I
got this new girl I swear down and you
know that proves to a fact that Tinder
does not give a single [__] not not they
have but they always they always use
this veil of like we actually you know
we have had success stories I fully
believe Tinder has some success stories
but you know some oh no no I I have a
friend from high school who married
there's definitely you know and and I
they use those stories as like look we
we are we are offering a valuable
function and at times they do but then
they pull [__] like this and other stuff
that they've done in the past where
they've made it so that like you
straight up just if you are an
undesirable man you just won't be
matched with anyone yeah uh because your
score is your your inapp score is too
low that's so [__] up um and then
offering $500 to me is say is
symbolizing and willing to take
advantage of people who are so desperate
to meet someone else it is it's not like
this guy who's found of the S he's happy
you are actively taking advantage of of
the loneliest people with money to burn
because listen any single person on
Earth that you meet up with if you tell
them you spent $500 on Tinder
immediately unattractive yeah there's no
one on earth who's going to find that
attractive totally I bet those those
dudes are the type of dudes that will
ask to split the bill anyway but um the
point being is that you're just wasting
$500 a month to be lonely it's it's it's
it's such a [__] awful idea uh and
I'm it's [__] embarrassing I hope
that they don't actually do it I hope
it's just a publicity St yeah please
don't do it like this don't the sad
thing is I don't think it is a publicity
stun I think they just want to make
money it's I think to for them it's a
legit business move which I think un
going to work they've obviously done
research before launching something like
this they've obviously identified a
market for this and you know a lot of
people are clowning on it but I think I
think those people who are clowning on
it were never going to be part of that
target audience anyway you know I think
there is that is a very specific target
audience and I think honestly uh there
is a market for it it's just now it's
just out there in the open there's
always been a market for it for yeah
people who want to find Partners who
have a lot of money and partners who are
willing to pay for that well when I
first moved to Japan I I I had uh Tinder
premium which allowed you to like
unlimited cuz I actually lonely I just
wanted to meet someone oh yeah because
there was a limit to how many Li right
and you know to me I was just like I
just want to have the highest chance
possible of being able to [__] meet
up with someone right um and then I
realize they what they do is they
constantly dangle ahead of you they're
like wait but like if you had this
feature pretty sure we can get you
somewh you are not a high enough rank
yeah but I was never going to do it CU I
was like I'm already paying [__] five
[__] dollars a month [__] you I give
you any more [__] money um and they
would just dangle these things in front
of you and they would add these
superficial features that just did not
help just straight up just did not help
um and you know T Tinder has proven if
you are of a certain
desirability uh you will just not have
success on Tinder it just because you're
you've you know the the app is figured
out that no one wants to [__] date
you based on your profile for whatever
reason and and no amount of money is
going to solve that problem so you you
know it's just cruel it's so cruel it's
yeah they're taking money to give you
the illusion that you still have a
chance yeah it's you [__] up and not
to mention all the fake profiles and
stuff like that and I very quickly gave
up on Tinder um in PS I was like [__]
this is stupid